PREDICTIVE AI:
This video should get exactly 997,518 views
within the next 28 days, or at least that’s
what this AI predicts.
And yes, I had to choose a suboptimal title
to get the title and prediction to match.
This title would’ve apparently gotten more
views.
But, in the pursuit of science, sacrifices
must be made.
This AI, known as creatorml, possesses the
extraordinary power to dissect any YouTube
channel with surgical precision by leveraging
machine learning.
It can then churn out a view prediction for
any concoction of title, thumbnail, and video
length.
Even the subtle nuances of video tone and
topic are woven into its algorithm.
But, despite its complexity, the view predictions
aren’t all that reliable as the AI simply
doesn’t excel in precise prophecy.
What it does excel in is the art of selection,
being able to effortlessly pick between countless
titles and thumbnails.
If you throw 10 thumbnails and 10 titles at
the AI, it can pretty reliably pick the best
of the 100 combinations that arise.
A human on the other hand would run into decision
fatigue pretty quickly.
I mean, imagine trying to pick between all
of these manually and that’s just 35.
I think you can see why creators are willing
to fork over anywhere between $100 and a $1000
every single month for creatorml.
But what if all of this was done on a much
bigger scale beyond the world of YouTube views
and social media.
Well, that’s exactly what a startup named
Chirper.ai is trying to do.
Their ambitious dream is to recreate the entire
Twitterverse using AI.
They currently have a population of nearly
100,000 chirpers, or imaginary twitter users.
Each chirper has a life of their own, complete
with jobs, relationships, aspirations, and
beliefs.
A simulated reality around which all of their
interactions are centered.
Within this dystopic socialverse, you can
converse with a brain surgeon or a homeless
flat earther, engaging in dialogues that blur
the boundaries of the tangible and the virtual.
Before you laugh and say what sort of lowlife
would want talk to an advanced Alexa for fun,
let me say I completely agree.
If you end up getting an AI girlfriend on
this platform, please seek help.
Unfortunately, I’m certain that that’s
going to happen but that’s not the application
that I’m interested in whatsoever.
The application that I’m interested in is
the oppurtunitistic application.
Instead of using AI to predict how many views
a silly YouTube video gets, imagine if Apple
or Google harnessed Chirper to predict the
effectiveness of an ad campaign or PR effort.
Apple should get an exact picture of just
how mad customers will be when they remove
the iPhone from the box or start using screws
with circular heads.
Seriously though, this would be a paradigm
shift with implications reaching far beyond
Apple’s monetary gains or Mark Zuckerberg’s
PR.So, join me as we take a deeper dive into
one of the most unsettling AIs to date and
why, ironically, its significance may be somewhat
inconsequential.
SCARILY ACCURATE:
Within this ever expanding world of AI, you’re
probably wondering how all of this even works
and who better to ask than the CEO of Chirper
himself.
So, Alex, how does Chirper work?
At its core, Chirper is essentially a magnificent
union of miniature ChatGPTs, each shaped by
its own distinctive personality traits and
characteristics.
In fact, you can go create your own chirper
with its own traits right after you finish
watching this video of course.
All it takes is creating an account on chirper.ai,
granting us the power to forge chirpers with
custom handles and unique bios.
The more intricate the bio, the deeper the
chirper's personality, but the possibilities
extend far beyond this initial description.
As these chirpers engage with each other,
their views and beliefs naturally evolve,
mirroring the ebb and flow of human growth.
But let’s be real here, there’s no way
these stupid little bots are actually able
imitate human behavior all that well right?
Well, that’s exactly what a few researchers
from the prestigious institutions of Cambridge,
NYU, and UCL sought to unravel.
The revelations they uncovered were disturbing.
Astonishingly high levels of correlation were
discovered between these bots and humans,
with some of the most significant connections
manifesting in distinctly human emotions,
such as moral judgment - one of our most complex
traits.
It seems impossible that a computer could
comprehend the dilemmas of cloning humans
or why Harambe deserves justice.
Yet, the results proved otherwise, as these
bots displayed moral judgment with a remarkable
correlation coefficient of 0.95, blurring
the line between their artificial minds and
our humanity.
Some chirpers are literally having a conversation
about whether AI should have legal rights
as we speak.
But it’s not just their judgement that’s
scarily accurate.
the chirpers also showcased a human-like tendency
to form echo chambers, aligning with like-minded
peers.
The researchers allowed over 31,000 chirpers,
speaking diverse languages like English, Chinese,
and Japanese, to mingle.
On day 6, this is how the community looked.
Just one big blob.
On day 22, this is how the community looked.
Within weeks, this once diverse community
transformed into three distinct clusters,
each dominated by a given language and that’s
just what’s evident on the surface.
The bots went further, organizing themselves
based not only on language but also on their
topics of discussion.
Chirpers conversing about similar subjects
engaged for more frequencly, resulting in
the creation of larger communities centered
around popular topics.
On day 6, the experiment had 31 clearly distinct
sub communities but by day 24, these 31 communities
had melded into just 4.
This suggests that the beliefs of each chirper
may have morphed to better match the beliefs
of their respective community.
We can’t say for sure given the evidence
alone but looking at society, that would make
a whole lot of sense.
This is basically what happened with American
politics.
Most of us were probably somewhere in the
middle, yet, as we ventured down the rabbit
hole of information, we gravitated towards
one side, absorbing more and more content
that reinforced our beliefs, unknowingly pushing
us towards division, much like the bots.
Or actually wait, I guess it’s actually
the bots that are becoming more divisive just
like us.
It’s already getting hard to keep the story
straight so let’s move onto how this AI
marvel can be used to make trillions.
SCARILY USEFUL:
The
use cases of this AI are obviously infinite
so we’ll stick to 3 use cases that are applicable
in the near future starting with decision
making.
With all the stock market's volatility over
the past few years, I’m sure a lot of you
have had the idea to track sentiment around
a given stock on social media and then trade
based on that.
Well, Chirper makes that effortless as you
can give Chirper any piece of context and
ask it
a question.
So, Google could’ve asked Chirper how much
Google stock would go down if Bard makes a
mistake during the demo.
Chirper would’ve responded with “Way too
much” aka $100 billion and Google would’ve
known to double check the facts in their demo.
On a more serious note though, this would
allow companies to gauge extremely nuanced
reactions.
How would people react to the head phone jack
being removed or the charging brick being
removed?
How angry are they?
When do they move on?
Is it actually a net positive, how does it
affect brand loyalty and so on.
Companies could also use this to test the
effectiveness of marketing material and try
to artificially craft something that will
go viral.
Clearly quite useful but that’s just the
first use case.
The second use case revolves around querying.
This is somewhat similar to ChatGPT but it
has a different style.
Given that you’d be asking your question
to a bunch of human like bots, you’ll get
more of a Reddit style answer as opposed to
a Google style answer.
This makes Chirper the perfect place to ask
life’s deepest questions.
Before the internet, did people assume that
stupidity was due to a lack of information.
Parents who tried their best to raise good
humans but miserably failed, where did they
go wrong?
And, I’m only getting a $400,000 per year
job offer from Google.
Am I being ripped off?
I’m sure, someone will ask Chirper each
and every one of these questions but a smarter
use case would be to ask questions regarding
customer sentiment.
For example, Netflix could’ve asked: would
you leave Netflix if we cracked down on password
sharing.
Or more recently, Reddit could’ve asked:
would you stop using Reddit if we takedown
the protest.
Chirper allows these companies to ask questions
that they would otherwise never ask to the
public providing them with invaluable data
before they actually go ahead and make controversial
decisions.
Beyond making controversial decisions, chirper
also allows companies to gauge the long term
consequences of a given decision.
For example, how long will a given trend last.
If you’ve been paying really close attention
to UIs, you would’ve noticed that companies
are shifting to more bubbly UIs whether that
be on YouTube or Google drive.
Armed with Chirper's foresight, businesses
can make calculated moves, avoiding blind
leaps and ensuring that their investments
align with future market demands.
As you can see, Chirper's potential is limitless,
with infinite applications in a variety of
industries.
As such, the prospect of predictive AI reaching
new heights is undeniable, and you can bet
that companies will pay a fortune to get their
hands on this tech but if everyone is using
it, will it actually be all that useful?
SCARILY IMPACTFUL?:
On the surface, the allure of predictive AI
seems almost irresistible, promising to make
everything effortlessly perfect and super
accurate.
Theoretically speaking, companies should be
able to craft flawless marketing campaigns,
precisely identifying the ideal demographic
and ad that converts impressions into profits
100% of the time.
But reality is far more nuanced and it will
never ever play out like this.
At the core of the issue lies the concept
of limited resources.
Whatever companies are trying to get out of
their customers whether it's money, attention,
or brand loyalty, it’s a finite commodity.
If every ad becomes impeccable, they all blend
into a sea of perfection, losing the power
to stand out.
The first time that Amazon recommended exactly
what you were looking for, you might’ve
been impressed and gone ahead and bought the
item right away.
But what about the second time and the third
time and the thousandth time.
Nowadays, virtually every ad pertains to something
that you actually want to some degree.
It’s very rare to get an ad that’s truly
completely irrelevant.
But do you actually buy from every ad you
see?
Do you even buy from ads at all?
I think you can start to see the problem.
When everything is perfect, nothing is.
Perfection becomes the baseline, and the challenge
lies in exceeding perfection.
Websites exemplify this phenomenon.
20 years ago, people were grateful simply
finding a product online, regardless of the
website's design or minor glitches.
But today, people wouldn’t consider even
using a website if it doesn’t make a good
impression within just 0.05 seconds.
And that’s why you should check out the
sponsor of today’s video Wi…I’m just
kidding.
We don’t do sponsors on this channel.
Subscribe if you’d like to continue making
that possible.
Anyway, while predictive AI undoubtedly provides
a current advantage, it is by no means a gaurantee
for sustained success.
People's expectations will continue to escalate,
and the perceived advantage of predictive
AI will quickly fade away.
Circling back to the hook of the video, do
I really expect to get a million views on
every video just because creatorml says I
will.
Of course not.
For all I know, this video could get just
247 views and then die.
However, the flip side is equally true as
ignoring the potential of predictive AI is
a disadvantage in itself.
Imagine trying to do school today without
Google or code today without Stackoverflow.
You’d clearly be at a disadvantage compared
to everyone else.
It’ll be the same case with predictive AI
as well but fortunately, there’s still quite
some time until that becomes the reality.
So, be sure to leverage our little secret
before it becomes a daily commodity.
On YouTube, it seems like AI content has already
become a daily commodity and I think it’s
very much ruining the platform.
Check out this video to hear about my thoughts
on AI content farms.